mein name ist ehrlich cibulka und ich
darf sich als vorsitzender der
präsidentenkonferenz des dachverbands
der wehr politischen vereine österreichs
ganz herzlich zum achten tag der
wehrpflicht begrüßen
erstmals 2014 wurde ein tag der
wehrpflicht begangen in erinnerung an
die volksbefragung am 20 jänner 2013 und
so ist unser tag der wehrpflicht damals
per akklamation begründet worden und
versteht sich als manifestation des
wählerwillens seit damals durfte ich am
beginn immer zahlreiche fest und
ehrengäste begrüßen heute ist das etwas
anders
der wunderschöne festzelt
industriellenvereinigung ist leer
dafür haben sie an den bildschirmen am
smartphone am tablet die möglichkeit via
livestream teilzunehmen
trotzdem gilt unser dank der
industriellenvereinigung für die
langjährige gastfreundschaft
heute sind nur einige referenten hier
und ein kleines team daher das bild und
film stelle die wir ganz herzlich der
der wir ganz herzlich für die
unterstützung danken und alle anwesenden
haben noch in der letzten stunde einen
coup schnelltest durchgeführt um
sicherzustellen dass wir uns
untereinander auch nicht anstecken
können und durch diesen live stream
haben wir erstmals auch die möglichkeit
deutlich mehr menschen als in der
vergangenheit zu erreichen
und es ist auch möglich gäste über
videoeinspielungen in unseren
tagesablauf zu integrieren und daher ist
es uns auch eine besondere freude und
ehre dass erstmals auch der
oberbefehlshaber des österreichischen
bundesheers der bundespräsident
grußworte am beginn dieser veranstaltung
spenden wird diesen folgen dann auch
grußworte der verteidigungsministerin
und mit diesen grußworten darf ich
nunmehr den achten tag der wehrpflicht
für eröffnet erklären
der herde teilnehmerinnen und teilnehmer
am tag der wehrpflicht
das letzte jahr war herausfordernd
wir alle leben ja immer noch mittendrin
in der korona pandemie sie war und ist
eine große bewährungsprobe für
österreich und für alle die hier leben
aber sowie corolla kann uns auch etwas
anderes zu überraschen blackouts
cyberattacken koordinierte
terroranschläge oder durch die
klimakrise ausgelöste naturkatastrophen
und schon steht von einem tag auf den
anderen unser alltag auf dem kopf nach
dem letzten jahr wissen wir alle wie
schnell das geht
ich bin davon überzeugt dass wir es
schaffen alle mit kraft entgegen zu
treten
aber einmal mehr braucht es dazu ein
gemeinsames handeln ein
gesamtstaatliches handeln und ein
einsatzfähiges österreichisches
bundesheer so können wir in zukunft
solide agieren egal was kommt
daher begrüße ich sehr den prozess der
gerade mit parlamentarischer begleitung
stattfindet der auftrag ist das
weiterentwickeln unserer streitkräfte
auf basis eines evidenzbasierten risiko
bildes und dieses risiko bild sagt ganz
klar die bedrohungen werden nicht
abnehmen
sie sind vielfach miteinander verknüpft
und sie können überraschend kommen
wie also treten wir dem entgegen mit
einem bundesheer das in seinen
fähigkeiten breit aufgestellt ist autark
agieren kann und durchhaltekraft hat am
ende dieses prozesses soll aber nicht
nur ein klarer reformplan stehen wer das
österreichische bundesheer fit für die
herausforderungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts macht es braucht dafür auch
die notwendigen finanziellen mittel
damit das bundesheer aktuelle und
zukünftige bedrohungen auch tatsächlich
bewältigen kann
und so die österreicherinnen und
österreicher und alle menschen die hier
leben schützen kann
in diesem sinne wünsche ich ihnen für
ihre heutige veranstaltung noch
informative vorträge und angeregte
diskussionen heute genau vor einem jahr
hat die frau bundesministerin claudia
tander hier die tagung eröffnet mit
grußworten heute liefert sie diese
grußworte in einer kurzen videobotschaft
sehr geehrter herr bundespräsident sehr
geehrter herr präsident des
fachverbandes wehrhaftes österreich sehr
geehrter herr generalstabschef sehr
geehrte ehrengäste aus der politik vor
soldatinnen und soldaten des präsents
ohne miliz standes sehr geehrte damen
und herren ich freue mich sehr dass es
trotz der korona bedingungen gelungen
ist dass wir zumindest mittels einer
online konferenz die mittlerweile
traditionelle veranstaltung am tag der
wehrpflicht doch heuer durchführen
können
flexibilität das ist ohnehin eine der
stärken des militärs und kommt dort
somit auch hier zum tragen
gerade jetzt ist sicherheitspolitik in
unglaublich wichtiges thema denn die
aktuelle 19 pandemie mit zahlreichen
assistenzeinsätze und
unterstützungsleistungen ist eines der
neuen szenarien die uns im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
beschäftigen allein schon im vorjahr
haben wir zusätzlich zur pandemie einige
der anderen szenarien
erlebt wenn wir zurückdenken an die
große cyber-attacke auf das
außenministerium zu beginn des jahres
2020 über waldbrände und andere
katastrophen einsetzen
bis zum furchtbaren terroranschlag
anfang november in wien aktuell steht
unser bundesheer neben den zahlreichen
cobit einsetzen wie flächendeckenden
testungen und jetzt auch bei den
impfungen der bevölkerung bei der
bewältigung der schneemassen in vielen
teilen österreichs im einsatz
all das geschieht neben dem
sicherheitspolizeilichen
assistenzeinsatz migration an
österreichs grenzen und enorme aufgaben
im inland mit der luftraumüberwachung
dem entminungsdienst darüber hinaus
leisten wir auch unseren
sicherheitspolitischen beitrag im
ausland derzeit sind knapp 1000
soldatinnen und soldaten weltweit in 16
missionen unterwegs um die
internationalen verpflichtungen die
österreich eingegangen ist auch zu
erfüllen unsere einsätze
die haben eines ganz klar gezeigt das
bundesheer ist die strategische reserve
der republik österreich und es muss dann
die sicherheitspolitischen
herausforderungen des einundzwanzigsten
jahrhunderts angepasst werden
mit dem entwicklungsprogramm unser heer
mit seinen zahlreichen projekten einem
historisch höchsten und zweimal in einem
jahr erhöhten budget investitionen in
die infrastruktur ausrüstung und gerät
sind wir auf dem besten weg dazu sehr
geehrte damen und herren das
österreichische bundesheer ist auf dem
weg zu einer großen veränderung die
klassische militärische
landesverteidigung ist und bleibt das
selbstverständlich des österreichischen
poker series es ist die ureigenste
aufgabe doch darüber hinaus müssen wir
weiter denken und unser bundesheer
bereit machen um die bevölkerung vor den
neuen bedrohungen und szenarien wie
cyber attacken blackouts pandemien
naturkatastrophen mit ihren folgen
schützen zu können
in diesem sinne wünsche ich alles gute
für die veranstaltung und ihnen
alles alles gute bleiben sie gesund
in den vergangenen jahren haben wir uns
intensiv mit verschiedenen
bedrohungsbild und beschäftigt im rahmen
der tage der wehrpflicht mit den
sogenannten hybriden bedrohungen und
zwar doch die frau minister gerade
angesprochen dass das fähigkeitsspektrum
quantitativ und qualitativ weit gespannt
sein muss auch der herr bundespräsident
hat darauf hingewiesen dass nicht nur
das wahrscheinliche sondern auch das
überraschende vorsorge benötigt wir
haben nunmehr einen wahren experten
hinsichtlich des bedrohungs bildes der
sich mit der frage das bedrohungsbild in
und um europa beschäftigen wird es ist
dieses kreative walter feichtinger
langjährige leiter des instituts für
friedenssicherung und konfliktmanagement
an der landesverteidigungsakademie
vielen auch bekannt aus seinen analysen
im fernsehen und von seinem blog
feuchtinger kompakt und er führt uns
heute in das thema sicherheitspolitisch
ein sehr geehrter herr präsident
geschätzte damen und herren es ist mir
eine ehre heute und hier
diesen vortrag machen zu können weil ich
zutiefst davon überzeugt bin dass es
wichtig ist seriös und umfassend zu
informieren keine panik zu verbreiten
aber doch den realitäten ins auge zu
schauen und genau das ist die absicht
der nächsten 20 minuten wenn ich hier
einen kleinen streifzug um europa herum
marke und auch nach österreich selbst
ein kleiner einblick heute presse
studium heute vormittag zwei
tageszeitungen blackout gefahr in europa
steigt das bvt ist alarmiert über und
umsturzpläne bei teilnehmen an den
demonstrationen in österreich dubiose
vorgänge um einen türkischen spion
proteste in tunesien jenem hoffnungs
land wo wir gedacht haben arabischer
frühling geschaffen ist wirklich ein
iranischer diplomat in komische vorgänge
verwickelt wo hier
stoff durch österreich geschleust werden
sollte und den libyen kein bisschen
hoffnung auf es ist unfassbar dass sie
es alleine ein kleiner auszug aus der
tageszeitung von heute und fast täglich
findet man ähnliche meldungen kann mir
gut vorstellen das ist ähnlich ist mit
corona dass man den überblick verliert
das man nicht mehr weiß was da
eigentlich abgeht und wie man sich
orientieren kann und wie groß die
gefahren die bedrohung tatsächlich ist
weil es hilft nichts wenn man sagt wir
sind ständig bedroht um die präsent und
ubiquitär sondern man muss sagen woher
kommt das und wie kann man dagegen
vorgehen
und das wäre genau mein versuch in den
nächsten minuten hier ein bisschen
struktur hinein zu bringen und zu wissen
wo wäre ein hebel anzusetzen und wie
sind die gefahren tatsächlich
einzustufen denn her ganz kurz geyer
geostrategische lage
ich halte das für unglaublich wichtig
weil die geopolitik und die geo
strategie ist immer ein ausdruck eines
welt befinden und aus dem abgeleitet
entsteht entspannung oder sie entstehen
spannungen und wir leben hier leider in
einer zeit wo die spannungen dominieren
und daher folgende fünf punkte wir
erleben den kampf um platz eins in der
welt es ist längst klar dass china den
usa in 10 20 jahren den rang ablaufen
will und dass die usa alles unternehmen
um das zu verhindern
das ist ein allgemeinplatz mittlerweile
nur das hat auswirkungen das hat
auswirkungen auch auf europa auch auf
einzelne staaten weil man in diesem
kampf hineingezogen wird einerseits man
muss sich positionieren muss partei
ergreifen das wird gefordert
auf der anderen seite entsteht ein
vakuum an vielen orten und dieses vakuum
hat natürlich den auswirkungen und
bewirkt veränderungen
wir sehen zweiter punkt spätestens 2014
eindeutig an die westliche sun ti
europäisches russland ich stelle das mit
großem bedauern fest weil der russland
ist und bleibt unser nachbar und eine
entspannung mit russland wäre
seiten sehr dienlich und sehr zweckmäßig
allerdings diese spannungen verstärken
sich eher als dass sie abnehmen und das
hat große auswirkungen auf das
bilaterale verhältnis und auch auf
unseren alltag und die sicherheitslage
in europa und am östlichen rand europas
dritter punkt wir haben leider auch
gerade in den letzten vier jahren
besonders zu bemerken doch gestört dass
transatlantisches beziehungsgeflecht das
gestört ist das ist ja schade weil die
sicherheit nach dem zweiten weltkrieg
und auch während des kalten krieges war
in hohem maße von einem großen
verständnis über den atlantik hinweg
geprägt und wir sind lange zeit unter
dem schutzschirm der usa hier gestanden
und tun das heute noch und der bröckelt
und da muss man sich wirklich überlegen
wie das hier weitergehen kann und was
europa hier tun kann und tun soll
nehmen wir doch einen nächsten punkt
dazu das ist der vormarsch der
regionalmächte wir sehen das gerade im
bereich des nahen und mittleren ostens
die türkei saudi arabien der iran
russland schon erwähnt sie versuchen
hier ihre pflöcke einzuschlagen und je
mehr sich die usa als ordnungsmacht
zurückziehen um so stärker treten sie
auf und dieses ringen um anerkennung
dieses ringen um macht und
positionierung verschafft natürlich
spannungen und das ist genau das
gegenteil von dem was man sich
eigentlich vorstellt und was man möchte
damit zum fünften punkt schwaches und
einiges europa man könnte auch sagen
sagen schwaches weil ein einiges europa
ein einiges europa werde ganz sicher
wesentlich stärker gut das ist ein
faktum ist mit sehr viel unternommen auf
seiten der eu allerdings europa konnte
dieses vakuum nicht fühlen dass die usa
hinterlassen zum bei inter lassen zb auf
dem westbalkan im nahen osten auch in
der in beziehung zur türkei und in
libyen
das heißt hier sind andere kräfte dann
auf den plan getreten die hier dieses
vakuum füllen und versuchen
ihren eigenen vorstellungen zu fühlen
was heißt dass unterm strich spannung
statt entspannung verunsicherung stadt
sicherung und das ist ganz dramatisch in
solchen situationen jede verunsicherung
erzeugt automatisch auch misstrauen und
misstrauen 14 im sicherheitsteam ein
sicherheits dilemma bedeutet dass man
dem anderen automatisch das schlechtere
unterstellt im extremfall dass sie mich
angreifen will
ohne dass ich vorbereitet will und wozu
führt dass das führt zu aufrüstung und
wir sehen dass wir heute bereits ganz
massiv weltweit in eine aufrüstung
hineingegangen sind wo wir nicht mehr
davon reden können dass hier
rüstungskontrolle im vordergrund steht
sondern ganz im gegenteil sowohl im
konventionellen wie auch im subventionen
und dem cyber bereich wird unglaublich
viel geld in die hand genommen und auch
bei den nuklearwaffen um sich selber
stärker zu machen und stärker dazu
stehen
damit lassen sich einige konfliktzonen
und regierungen ableiten
ich darf hier mit einer konfliktzonen
nord und ost das ist die europäische
grenze zu russland im politischen sinne
einfach einfach anführen und ich darf ja
auch mit einem bild vielleicht ein
bisschen aufräumen
seit jahren geistert der begriff ring of
fire um europa herum durch die gegend
minister sie ein bisschen übertrieben
weil es brennt nicht alles mir gefällt
viel besser das bild von vulkanen europa
ist eigentlich von einer
vulkanlandschaft umgeben wo manche
bereits ausgebrochen sind wo manche
knapp davor sind und wo manche brodeln
und wir wissen nicht wann es wieder
losgehen könnte und viele stellen sich
die frage ist europa nicht selber auch
ein vulkan oder sitzt es auf einem
vulkan wenn es nicht die richtigen
maßnahmen für die zukunft ergreift
schauen wir uns die einzelnen punkte an
beginnen wir
mit dieser linie die sich eigentlich
hier durch den osten zieht und wo wir
einzelne vulkane haben wir haben hier
ein verhalten wie im kalten krieg es
finden u-boot manöver statt es geht um
die kontrolle des eintritts in den
atlantik es geht darum dass man hier
wieder u boote vor schwedens häfen
auftauchen lässt und dergleichen das
sind alles gebärden die wir aus dem
kalten krieg kennen und wo wir
eigentlich gedacht haben das ist vorbei
im grunde genommen geht es um
machtdemonstration um stärke
demonstration und um verunsicherung auf
der anderen seite schauen wir weiter
es ist in vielen bereichen russland dass
wir diese maßnahmen setzen wie sie sein
russland das sich gegen den westen gegen
europa abschottet um negative einflüsse
staatsgefährdende einflüsse zu
verhindern
eine farben revolution ist das letzte
was man in moskau haben will
daher gilt es dem vorzubeugen um
vorbeugend tut man in dem es sich eben
abschottet und den anderen sogar
verunsichert und gefährdet gehen wir
weiter wir kennen die situation in
weißrussland die sache ist noch nicht
gelaufen aber russland hat bereits alles
unternommen um hier nachhaltig seine
position zu festigen und das
weißrussland nicht in den westlichen
einfluss bereich sprich eu und nato
gerät schauen wir weiter in den bereich
der ukraine ost ukraine wir kennen das
die creme annexion 2014 sich zu einer
weiteren entfremdung geführt hat und der
krieg im dom was ist leider auch noch
nicht beendet es leide sehr viele leute
darunter und der effekt daraus ist dass
die ukraine nicht voll integriert werden
kann sie selber nicht voll entscheiden
kann welchen weg ist eigentlich gehen
möchte in der nächsten zeit in den
nächsten 20 jahren dann haben wir noch
jüngst eine ereignis im südkaukasus wo
hier auch russland durch sehr
geschicktes agieren eigentlich eine
situation für sich zu nutzen wusste sie
wissen dass der konflikt um
berg-karabach wieder ausgebrochen ist
dass aserbaidschan mit hilfe der türkei
söldner und drohnen ganz maßgeblich im
einsatz
hier neue verhältnisse geschaffen hat
und fast alles wieder zurückgeholt hat
russlands position wurde dadurch
gestärkt und was wir gesehen haben ist
eingefrorene konflikte brechen
irgendwann wieder auf und das ist genau
dort zu beobachten gewesen und es gibt
noch andere eingefrorene konflikte die
aufbrechen können
damit gehe ich gleich in eine zweite
zone
die zweite zone ist für mich das süd
osten und der süden habe möchte ich auf
einen zweiten begriff hinweisen dass ist
der arabische frühling er hat mir von
anfang an missfallen weil er weckt
eigentlich unrealistische erwartungen
frühling ist was schönes der blüht da
geht es vorwärts wir haben von anfang an
gewusst das ist nicht so zu erwarten
und wenn man in diesen gegen schaut dann
ist es besser von einer billion zu
sprechen von einer rebellion im
arabischen raum was einige länder ganz
schlimm erwischt hat syrien und libyen
ganz besonders und wo sogar tunesien
eigentlich nicht wirklich den wandel
schon komplett gesichert hat und wenn er
heute zehn jahre nach diesem jahrestag
der selbstverbrennung hier massenprotest
in verschiedenen städten stattfinden die
armee zum einsatz kommt dann zeigt dass
das ist ein unglaublich mühsamer prozess
hier eine transformation in richtung
demokratie und menschenrechte und
öffnung zu machen aber ganz kurz dazu
der konflikt in syrien den krieg ins
juden die große schlacht ist geschlagen
aber es ist noch nicht beendet wir haben
noch eine konzentration im nordwesten in
idlib wo tausende von dschihadisten
eingekesselt sind und wo man eigentlich
erwartet wie kann es hier weitergehen
es ist nicht erledigt und die gefahr
besteht dass hier weitere flüchtlinge
über das land kommen und vor allem auch
die dschihadisten versuchen auszubrechen
und in ihre herkunftsländer zurück zu
gehen oder ihren kanzler anders hin zu
tragen
nehmen wir
gleich den nachbar türkei dazu türkei in
syrien auf massiv involviert die türkei
soll die eigentlichen stabilitätsanker
in dieser region seien als nato mitglied
durch diese erdgassuche und durch diese
machtansprüche in der region inklusive
libyen ist ja das gegenteil eingetreten
mann ist verunsichert was will die
türkei wie weit ist es bereit zu gehen
wenn man gas erkundung schiffe durch
militärschiffe begleiten lässt dann ist
das kein gutes zeichen und wie man
manöver in diese richtung ab führt das
heißt wir haben hier eigentlich
innerhalb europas ein großes
spannungsfeld derzeit deutet wieder
einiges auf entspannung aber hier ist
auch die geschichte noch nicht am ende
des tages angelangt nehmen wir eine
weitere region gehen wir hinein richtung
irak und iran im irak mühsam der versuch
normalität einkehren zu lassen ein krieg
das über viele jahre ein krieg der viele
jahre hier geherrscht hat und die
gesellschaft kriegsmüde ist aber es ist
noch immer ein spannungsfeld und wenn
sie hier den pfeil sehen dann ist das
der wesentliche hintergrund für viele
dieser konflikte oder ein konflikt
treiber
das ist das ringen zwischen saudi
arabien und dem iran und die dominanz im
arabischen raum in dieser region
und solange dieser kampf in dieser
vehemenz geführt wird werden wir auch
bei den einzelnen kriegsschauplätzen
keine wesentliche verbesserung erkennen
können also wieder das übergeordnete
problem ein politisches zwei
regionalmächte die hier im regen stehen
wer ist stärker jemand leider noch nicht
aus den schlagzeilen verschwunden erst
unlängst wieder haben die usa die eu die
rebellen als rebellen organisation
eingestuft und das hat massive
auswirkungen
damit sind die aus politischen prozessen
eigentlich herausgedrängt worden und
ohne politische lösung wird man auch
hier im jemen keine nachhaltige lösung
finden können das ist ja massives
problem
und hier ist man aufgerufen auch wieder
einen politischen lösungsansatz zu
finden
und eines darf man nicht vergessen es
gibt noch den islamischen staat diese
terror organisation und die ist zwar ein
kalifat vernichtet dieser gottesstaat
wurde vernichtet aber es gibt noch
tausende kämpfe in der region
sie sind in den untergrund gegangen sie
führen bereits wieder übergriffe durch
und sie warten nur darauf dass man hier
sich wieder stärker strukturieren kann
und dass die aufmerksamkeit des staates
wege wird und der intern als sein
gemeinschaft um wieder an einfluss zu
gewinnen
und dort sind die geistigen spin
doktoren auch für terroranschläge in
europa nach wie vor das hat sich nicht
geändert und das wird sich auch nicht so
schnell ändern
und hier werden wir sicher sehen dass
diese geschichte mit terroranschlägen in
europa leider noch nicht beendet ist ist
der kern hier in dieser region und auch
wieder politische ansatz erforderlich
gehen wir weiter nach libyen libyen für
europa von größter bedeutung und libyen
hat natürlich hier das riesenproblem
dass es eigentlich einen krieg begonnen
hat einen aufstand gegen gaddafi
begonnen hat ohne konzept für nachher
und wenn man keinen plan hat für nachher
dann passiert genau das was in libyen
war wir haben dort terroristen wir haben
eine spaltung des landes wir haben
mühsame internationalen
friedensinitiativen momentan schaut sie
ein bisschen besser aus dass man eine
gemeinsame übergangsregierung machen
kann
aber das ist nicht zum ersten mal und
ich bin ein bisschen skeptisch wie die
sache weitergeht damit weiter zum
nächsten punkt jetzt könnte man sagen
was geht uns das an
wir sitzen in europa man muss leider
sagen das geht uns alle sehr viel an
weil wenn diese vulkanisch bei das
fliegende trümmer sehr weit und die
asche kann sich weit nach europa hinein
ziehen und es wurde in den vorigen
beiträgen ja schon angesprochen weil er
jeden von migration inklusive mit umwelt
demografische entwicklung
bevölkerungszunahme vor allem junge
leute in der region um keine hoffnung
keine zukunftsperspektive
das heißt der migrationsdruck wird
sicher nicht abnehmen wir haben der hier
in europa
damit umzugehen wir haben uns darauf
einzustellen ich gehe hier ganz kurz
drüber hybride bedrohungen sind an der
tagesordnung da brauchen wir gar nicht
darüber reden dass begriff die kleine
firma genauso wie das aussenministerium
oder den flughafen in österreich wir
haben hier die gefahrenlage und das
gefahrenbewusstsein das in hohem maße
glaube ich noch unterentwickelt ist
wir haben einfach keine zeit gehabt wo
man über krieg und frieden und alles was
das bedrohung kann die sicherheit nicht
zu wirklich nachdenken müssen das fehlen
uns jetzt ein bisschen auf den kopf
allgemein staatlich wie auch in der
gesellschaft wir müssen uns mit dem
phänomen einfach stärker
auseinandersetzen und was sich sehr wohl
geändert hat verschärft hat in den
letzten jahren das ist die fruchtbarkeit
wir sind auf politischer ebene
verwundbar durch propaganda durch
cyber-angriffe durch alle möglichen
einflüsse
das sind gesellschaftlich verwundbar es
gibt sehr viele versuche die
gesellschaft zu spalten und hier einfach
unfrieden hinein zu bringen und wir sind
natürlich wirtschaftlich in höchstem
maße abhängig querverweis corona woher
kommen die medikamente china indien in
hohem maße und der abhängigkeiten über
die man auch das nachdenken muss wir
haben defizite im sicherheitsbereich
gerade militärischen das wurde schon
angesprochen aber ich würde hier auch
die geistige komponente nicht ausnehmen
das ist ganz ganz wichtig sich mit dem
thema auseinanderzusetzen zu sagen was
ist für unsicherheit wie kann es
weitergehen
schwache zusammenhalt sowohl auf
europäischer ebene wie auch auf
staatlicher manchmal wir sehen derzeit
gerade das auf und ab wie leicht
meinungen zu beeinflussen sind aber in
starker zusammenhalt ist wichtig um
spaltungen hintanzuhalten und dann darf
ich noch dazu nehmen
es wird immer erwähnt dass die nato ja
sowieso die sicherheit europas im harten
kern die militärischen bereich
garantiert sagte er mache ich ein
fragezeichen dazu weil das funktioniert
nur solange die usa bereit sind so viel
einzubringen wie bisher
und daher die diskussion in europa dass
man den europäischen arm stärker
aufstellt dass man die europäische
kapazitäten entwickeln muss weil es
keine garantie gibt dass die usa
weiterhin auch so stark für europa
sicherheit bringen
und wenn in wenigen minuten der
amerikanische präsident seinen an zeit
leidet dann gehe ich davon aus dass er
zwar sehr viele freundlichere worte
gegenüber europa findet aber europa
trotzdem in der pflicht bleibt oder ob
es oder um es mit der deutschen
kanzlerin zu sagen wir müssen das
schicksal in die eigenen hände nehmen
damit den ausblick
die trends die durchwegs hier gezeichnet
wurden auch von den vorrednern bleiben
erhalten
wir müssen uns auf stürmische zeiten
einstellen aber wir haben einen
regenschirm wir können schutz bauen wir
können uns entsprechend vorbereiten also
nach regen kann ja auch wieder sonne
kommen
wir müssen mit überraschungen rechnen
das ist auch klar das haben wir mehrfach
erlebt und der herr bundespräsident hat
das angesprochen das ist ein
wesentliches phänomen heute mit den
heutigen technologien ist man in der
lage völlig überraschend völlig ohne
vorbereitung einen start ganz hart zu
treffen mit sauber angreifen mit
diversen maßnahmen aber auch dass wenn
man einmal geistig verinnerlicht hat ist
nicht mehr so schlimm als wenn man
wirklich total überrascht wird damit
würde ich abschließend sagen sicherheit
beginnt in den köpfen und daher sind
veranstaltungen wie diese wahnsinnig
wichtig um hier entsprechende beiträge
zu leisten
herzlichen dank
herzlichen dank herr brigadier
feuchtinger für diese tour doris die
verschiedenen konfliktzonen die rund um
europa angeordnet sind und wir machen
nunmehr auch einen blick über die
landesgrenzen hinaus andere länder
andere sitten sagt man und in den acht
jahren in denen wir den tag der
wehrpflicht begehen hatten wir noch
keine internationalen gäste die sich
hier eingebracht haben und diesmal gibt
es insofern eine neuigkeit wir haben die
verteidigungsattachés der schweiz und
von schweden eingeladen ihre sicht auf
die sicherheitslage darzulegen und auch
die nationalen vorgehensweisen der
schweiz und schweden zu skizzieren unser
nachbarland schweiz an dem ja
bekanntlich unsere neutralität sich ein
beispiel nehmen soll
ist vielleicht heute insoferne anders zu
sehen als die der jubel kein eu-beitritt
der schweiz stattgefunden hat schweden
hingegen ist zeitgleich mit österreich
der eu beigetreten war bis zu diesem
zeitpunkt ein neutrales land bezeichnet
sich nunmehr als bündnis frei der
attaché von schweden obersten und ist
für deutschland und österreich zuständig
er hat seinen dienst fort in berlin und
konnte aufgrund der chor ohne regeln
heute nicht eintreffen er wird aber mit
einer videobotschaft eingespielt aber
zuvor live hier vor ort der
verteidigungsattaché unseres
nachbarlandes schweiz oberst im
generalstab und sulzer herzlich
willkommen
schweizer armee ich freue mich ihnen
heute einige worte sagen zu können wie
die schweiz mit diesen potentiellen
vulkanausbrüchen umgeht
der titel den ich gewählt habe kämpfen
schützen helfen ist sehr bewusst gewählt
und zwar kämpfen kann kann schützen wer
schützen kann kann helfen aber es ist
nicht automatisch dass jeder der helfen
kann auch schützen kann und jeder der
schützen kann auch kämpfen kann
ich werde also versuchen ihnen heute
einige aspekte der sicherheitspolitik
der neutralen schweiz und zur schweizer
armee darzulegen
die bewaffnete neutralität der schweiz
der wiener kongress von 1815 ist quasi
die geburtsstunde unserer schweizer
neutralität die neutralität die seite
einer der wichtigsten grundsätze der
aussenpolitik der schweiz
sie bedeutet dass sich die schweiz nicht
an bewaffneten konflikten zwischen
anderen staaten beteiligt schweizerische
neutralität ich den grundsatz selbst
gewählt dauernd und bewaffnet sie wird
nicht als selbstzweck sondern als ein
instrument verstanden als ein instrument
der schweizerischen außen und
sicherheitspolitik inhalt und auslegung
jedoch diese neutralität die haben sich
im laufe der geschichte gewandelt die
bundesverfassung von 1848 sie war der
meilenstein wo die schweiz zu einem
bundesstaat geworden ist und zuvor war
es ein staatenbund hier in dieser
bundesverfassung ist bereits auch
indirekt die aufgabe der schweizer armee
festgelegt die schweizerische
eidgenossenschaft schützt die freiheit
und die rechte des volkes und war die
unabhängigkeit und sicherheit des landes
was mir besonders gefällt auf dieser
grafik die sie sehen die
bundesverfassung wird getragen
vom volk aber auch von bewaffneten vom
militär
man sieht auf dieser grafik zudem dass
die militärs verschiedene uniformen
hatten weil die kantone noch
selbstständig waren und ganz an die
basis der bundesverfassung ist natürlich
auch die kantone aus dem video der
schweizer armee sechs irrtümer bezüglich
sicherheit hier nur ein kurzer auszug
von 3 irrtümer
[Musik]
immer gilt die höchste terror warnstufe
selbst ist die zahl der todesopfer auf
25 angestiegen darunter 20 uhr ist
[Musik]
unabhängigkeitsplatz mai dann kam es zur
totalen straßenschlacht
es blickt der westen weiter auf die ost
ukraine
die islamistische gruppe boko haram
terrorisiert nigeria
[Musik]
also wir haben drei irrtümer gesehen
irrtum nummer eins bei der gefährdung
der inneren sicherheit braucht es nur
die polizei irrtum nummer zwei moderne
konflikte oder kämpfe die finden nur am
computer oder im fernsehen statt und
irrtum nummer drei für friedensförderung
im ausland braucht es nur wie viele
mittel nun aber zurück zum auftrag der
armee in der bundesverfassung ist dieser
gegeben und da bereits ist festgelegt
dass die schweizer armee nach dem
prinzip der minis organisiert ist das
heißt in der schweiz hat jeder
wehrpflichtige mann ist einerseits der
mann hat eine militärische karriere
andererseits eine zivile karriere und
dann ist ebenfalls festgelegt dass die
amedia kriegs verhinderung dient das ist
glaube ich philosophisch ein sehr
wichtiger punkt also die den klima wir
möchten mit der schweiz habe nie einen
krieg gewinnen müssen sondern wir
möchten mit der schweizer armee einen
glaubwürdigen beitrag leisten dass ein
potenzieller agresso überzeugt die ist
dass sich aufwand und ertrag nicht lohnt
im militärgesetz sind andere elemente
des auftrags der schweiz rami festgelegt
zum beispiel wird präzisiert dass wenn
sie viele behörden probleme haben und
die mieten nicht mehr ausreichen die
armee helfen kann
zu den instrumenten der
sicherheitspolitik das ist wie eine
werkzeugkiste wie eine toolbox alle
gelben werkzeuge aber auch die grünen
elemente die sie hier sehen die müssen
vorhanden sein ein werkzeug der richtige
schraubenzieher in diesem werkzeugkasten
fehlt dann funktioniert das nicht mit
meinen knapp 15 jahren ausland
erfahrungen wo ich oftmals vor ort
krisen beobachten konnte bin ich
persönlich zur überzeugung gekommen dass
eine existenz der armee das heißt eine
rückfall option oftmals die
unausgesprochene voraussetzung dafür ist
dass außenpolitik auf dem
verhandlungsweg ziele erreichen kann hat
man keinen glaubwürdigen hebel
dann können diplomaten noch so engagiert
so fähig sein aber es wird schwierig an
verhandlungen etwas erreichen zu können
in den weiß den meisten westlichen
ländern so natürlich auch in der schweiz
gilt das primat der politik das heißt
die politische ebene hier in blau die
entscheidet und die armee das militär
hat umzusetzen nun sein fall ist die
politische ebene natürlich das parlament
national und ständerat zusammen mit der
exekutive im bundesrat die länder bei
uns heißt dass die kantone die werden
natürlich bei der entscheidungsfindung
angehört kommen wir zurück zu kämpfen
schützen helfen ein kampf der findet
statt in einem raum dass khan sein am
boden oder im luftraum aber heute konnte
street das element dazu ganz wichtig der
cyber das ist informationsraum das ist
propaganda das ist fair news das ist
beeinflussung operationen und das
beeinflusst sich alles gegenseitig wenn
wir die drei säulen nochmals nehmen
kämpfen schützen helfen dann entspricht
das dem gis das kämpfen dem gesamtsystem
verteidigung das schützen der
unterstützung der zivilen behörden auf
deren antrag natürlich und das helfen
die friedensförderung im ausland
unterstützt wird die armee dabei durch
die elbe durch die logistikbasis der
armee und durch die food durch die
führungsunterstützungsbasis der armee
man kann auch sagen durch das
militärische telekom betrieb die
schweizer armee ist selbstverständlich
kein statischer zustand kein staat
dieser organismus
sondern in einer weiterentwicklung
begriffen nach dem ende des kalten
krieges hat man gewisse entscheidungen
getroffen die zur schwächungen geführt
haben und mit der wehr der
weiterentwicklung der armee versucht man
jetzt diese schwächen wieder zu beheben
seien hier vier bereiche erwähnt die
erhöhung der bereitschaft da hat man zb
die mobilmachung nach dem ende des
kalten krieges massiv geschwächt das
wird jetzt korrigiert dann hat man aus
rücksicht auf die universitäten auf die
studenten auf die im privaten
unternehmungen die kaderausbildung im
militär angepasst die das hat schwächen
ergeben das wird jetzt wieder korrigiert
auch um geld zu sparen hat man nicht
mehr sämtliche einsatzverbände
ausgerüstet sondern hat puls gebildet
und das hat dazu geführt dass man bei
einer kriegs mobil machen nicht mehr
sämtliche verbände hätte auslösen können
da sie hat auch korrigiert und dann ist
es immer wichtig dass eine streikkraft
wurzeln hat in der region verankert ist
und diese wurzeln werden ist auch wieder
vertieft stichwort territorial
divisionen zwei worte zur
führungsstruktur der schweizer armee
wir haben einen chef der armee
dann haben wir darunter auch in blau
drei große führungsbereich das ist der
einsatzbereich unterstützungsbereich und
die ausbildung der bereich unterstützung
kann man dann noch untergliedern in
logistikbasis und
führungsunterstützungsbasis der armee
hier noch die verantwortlichen offiziere
die diese bereiche führen ganz an der
spitze der chef der schweizer armee
korpskommandant süßlich hier nur ein
einziger als illustration ein einziger
bereich hervorgehoben das kommando
operationen unter kommandant lomi show
bei ihm ist angegliedert das heer und
die luftwaffe und weitere
verbände in der schweiz ist es immer
sehr wichtig darauf hinzuweisen dass das
verhältnis zwischen ziviler gesellschaft
zwischen wirtschaft industrie und dem
militär andererseits eine win win
situation darstellt
es ist klar man muss zugeben die
wirtschaft muss arbeitnehmer frei
spielen damit diese ihren militärdienst
ableisten können sei es für
ausbildungskurse oder gruppen dienste
aber im militär lernen die wärmen und
die offiziere die charta
entscheidungsfindung und führen unter
zeitdruck und unter stress diese
fähigkeiten bringen sie zurück in die
industrie und das ist ein gewinn wenn
man heute die kosten von teambuildings
event im zivilen bereich oder von
management kursen von führungs kursen
anschaut dann sieht man wie groß dieser
mehrwert auch finanziell ist für die
unternehmungen nun zu den finanzen wie
viel geld hat die schweiz drei jahren
zur verfügung wir haben rund 5
milliarden schweizer franken das ist
unwesentlich weniger als fünf milliarden
euro pro jahr zur verfügung in rot
dargestellt dass sich der
betriebsaufwand 3 milliarden euro pro
jahr
das sind die löhne von fix angestellten
von reparaturen unterhalt an material
treibstoff und so weiter und dann die
große der große blaue kuchenstück eine
milliarde pro jahr
das ist bei rüstungsbeschaffungen das
größte beschaffungs paket das wir im
moment haben dies die beschaffung neuer
kampfflugzeuge
das sind 8 milliarden schweizer franken
vorgesehen und da kann man sich schon
vorstellen wie schwierig dieses paket zu
stemmen ist wenn man pro jahr nur eine
milliarde zur verfügung hat das heißt so
eine beschaffung muss über mehrere jahre
finanziell verteilt werden noch einmal
das projekt eher 2030 also der satz und
so
ans ende der lebensdauer kommenden f 18
kampfflugzeuge
das ist ein großprojekt wir sind darauf
kurs und zwar die regierung der
bundesrat hat im jahr 2017 den
grundsatzentscheid getroffen neue mittel
zu beschaffen
zwei jahre später 2009 10 hat das
parlament ja gesagt dazu und im
vergangenen jahr 2020 konnte die
schweizer bevölkerung sich dazu äußern
und entscheiden und hat ebenfalls wenn
auch knapp ja gesagt das heißt dieses
großprojekt er 2030 ist im moment gut
auf kurs
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
sehr geehrte bundespräsident von der
generäle
meine damen und herren vielen dank für
die einladung zum achten tag der
wehrpflicht
ich heiße rhythmen und bin aber schwer
zu österreich schwedens ich werde einen
kurzen impuls vortrag über die lage und
entwicklung in schweden halten den
vorschlag während in drei teilen
gestartet erstens über die strategische
lage schwedens danach die letzte
entwickeln und danach die jüngsten
verteilung muss ein schuss wie wir die
[Musik]
eben das siegel für 25 schweden ist wohl
wissen ein ganz großes land die fläche
schwedens ist größer als die von
österreich und deutschland zusammen
in schweden haben wir auch eine ganz
kleine bevölkerung nur ungefähr zehn
millionen einwohnern
das ist ein wichtiger grund daten für
eine strategische verteidigungskonzept
schreiben hat auch eine lange küste dem
nordmeer und auch an die ostsee das ist
wichtig zu wissen
dabei haben wir auch eine große insel in
der mitte der ostsee
das ist ja eingeschätzt aussehe
strategisch in schweden ist auch fast
alle ausländischen export und import
über den mehr angekommen und abgeschickt
dabei ist die hev fans schwedens im
westen auf außerordentliche bedeutung
das kommt zusammen das schwedische
schwedische führung hat fünf jungs
strategisch wichtige gebiete in schweden
ausgezeichnet das ist im norden in
lappland das ist eins dann ist diese
drei ballungsräume stockum als
hauptstadt
pauli als hafen
[Musik]
schwerpunkt und im süden in einmal mehr
als scheune schwedens wo die masse der
landwirtschaft befindet sich dann über
diese vier haben wir dann die insel
gotland das ist ausgezeichnet als sehr
wichtig dann gehe ich rüber zur die die
letzte entwicklung machte mal kalten
krieg schweden aufgerüstet und auch viel
mehr internationale beziehungen
mitgemacht
der wichtige schritt ist vielleicht in
der 90er als schweden mitglied der eu
geworden ist
danach haben wir einen schwerpunkt
internationale einsätze aus
militärischer sicht gesetzt und sind
immer dabei große einsätze wie in kosovo
und afghanistan
nach der entwicklung die wo er geblieben
ist hat dann schweden angefangen zum
aufrüsten
die lage schreibens macht es ja ganz nah
nach zu den gebieten im osten
die wehrpflicht war ausgesetzt in 2000
sehen muss und ist 2017 wieder
eingeführt die angefangene aufrüstung
mit dem entschluss von 15 ist mit dem
entschluss für 21 25 wieder
in schweden fassen das parlament
fünfjährige verteidigungs entschluss das
heißt auch dass es wird ein beste
planungs und es wird auch eine größere
zustimmung zu dem entschluss war im 5er
im fünf jahre wird sicher mindestens
eine parlamentswahl durchgeführt den
jungs der verteidigungs entschluss ist
im dezember gesegnet im parlament es
geht über die jahre an und 20 bis 25
einige merkmale da ist besonderes die
erhöhung der verteidigungsetat vom
diesem jahr wird es ungefähr 6 und haupt
milliarden euro betragen und bis 25
jahren 8,2 milliarden euro
dass sie ist dann dass es entspricht 1,5
prozent der big ich werde gut einige
sachen über die beteiligung und
die ziele jetzt werden man kann sagen
dass die verteidigung sich der ex
politik beruht auf drei säulen erstens
militärische verteidigung bis 2025
sollen schweden dann vier brigaden haben
jeder mit wehrpflichtige die
wehrpflichtige werden ausgeblendet neun
bis elf monate
schwerpunkt ist die luftverteidigung die
luftwaffe sich vor mindestens 100 jahre
skripten zu operieren
das heißt dass neben die neuen version
werden die esa dora versionen behalten
die marine hat als speerspitze dann 5 u
boote und 5 tagen pro wetten
die zweite säule besteht auf
internationale zusammenarbeit
hierbei hat schweden die zusammenarbeit
im bereich militär sehr vertieft
[Musik]
besonderes die zusammenarbeit und die
vorbereitungen für militärische hilfe
zwischen schweden und finnland ist zu
erwähnen
daneben ist es natürlich als eu-mitglied
auch eine sache unionspartnern zu sein
wir haben auch im norden eine besondere
zusammenarbeit motto das heißt nord is
not ist
bei uns zusammenarbeit wo die nordische
länder sich über ansprach anschaffung
und übungen etc
wir koordinieren
zwei andere staaten haben wir eine
vertiefte zusammenarbeit mit das ist die
usa wo wir viel mehr lieben mit und auch
die anschaffung von patriot-raketen als
eine bedeutende partner haben und
england haben wir auch eine
zusammenarbeit weil wir sind ja partner
und teilnimmt in sehr steilen die dritte
säule oder das ist vielleicht das ganze
das könnte man sagen ist die gesamte
verteidigung dass alle ämter und in
schweden sich besser vorbereiteten
umsatz arbeiten zusammen um schweden zu
verteidigen
dabei liegt auch eine entwicklung um
einen besser cyber verteidigung zu
kriegen aber auch die vorbereitung mit
vorreiter und sonstige das wird auch ein
entwicklung und eine erhöhung unterhalb
des verteidigungs entschlusses sein
das schließe ich den vorschlag ab und
bedanke mich für ihre aufmerksamkeit
herzlichen dank herr oberst edlund für
den beitrag falls sie gerade über den
livestream zu schauen
herzliche grüße nach berlin und auch
herzlichen dank hier vor ort an herr
oberst sowieso für seinen beitrag über
die schweizer armee nach diesen beiden
einblicken nunmehr ins befreundete
europäische ausland obliegt es dem herrn
dr anhalt kamen ableitungen für
österreich hier in unsere veranstaltung
einzubringen drk mail ist der
kabinettchef der frau bundesminister und
er ist auch leiter der direktion für
sicherheitspolitik und er hat damit
genau jene position immer die
gewissermassen die schnittstelle ist
zwischen politischen vorgaben und
militärischen umsetzungen und so hat
auch in den letzten monaten sie haben
wahrscheinlich im vergangenen halbjahr
diskussionen in der öffentlichkeit mit
verfolgt sondern den letzten monaten
evaluierungen das bedrohungsbild
stattgefunden und es wurden verschiedene
varianten für zukünftige
fähigkeitsprofil des österreichischen
bundesheeres ausgearbeitet die sie sind
noch nicht in der öffentlichen
diskussion aber es steht sozusagen eine
entscheidung unmittelbar ins haus wie
denn sich dieses österreichische
bundesheer weiterentwickeln sollen
und so sind wir sehr froh und sehr stolz
die entscheidenden eine entscheidende
person in diesem prozess hier heute zu
gast zu haben und vor allem auch das
sehr drk mail bereit erklärt hat uns ein
bisschen einen einblick in den aktuellen
stand der dinge zu geben
er hat auch der kammern der schleusen
des herzlich willkommen sehr geehrter
herr präsident meine geschätzten damen
und herren es ist mir eine besondere
freude und ehre heute an
achten tag der wehrpflicht hier bei
ihnen im saal der iv zwar in einem
anderen ambiente als gewohnt aber doch
aktiver hier teilnehmen zu dürfen und
ich danke auch für die freundliche ein
begleitung durch brigadier
sicherheitspolitik 20 21 sind unsere
antworten zeitgemäß lautet der treffende
titel des heurigen symposiums anlässlich
des tages der wehrpflicht welche
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitischen
ableitungen lassen sich für österreich
treffen
dies ist die herausforderung die mir
insbesondere in meiner funktion als
mieter führung betraut dem leiter der
direktion für sicherheitspolitik
gestellt wurde
hinzu kommt die herausforderung dass
auch wenn wir die letzte stunde revue
passieren lassen vieles bereits gesagt
wurde wir haben einblicke in das
risikobild und die bedrohungsanalyse von
brigadier feichtinger bekommen wir haben
von benachbarten befreundeten ländern
die einblicke erhalten wie sie mit
diesem geänderten bedrohungsbild und dem
sicherheitspolitischen umfeld auf
nationaler ebene entsprechend begegnen
herr brigadier cibulka hat das auch
eingangs bereits erwähnt der herr
bundespräsident hat dies auch in seiner
grussbotschaft verkündet wir stehen im
rahmen des bundesministeriums für
landesverteidigung gerade mitten in
einem prozess um auch diese an die die
richtigen fragen mit blick auf die
sicherheitspolitik im jahr 20 21 zu
stellen und daraus auch zeitgemäße
antworten hier entsprechend abzuleiten
gestatten sie mir zu beginn noch einen
kurzen rückblick auf bereits gesagt es
hier zu tätigen
brigida feichtinger hat in seinem ein
leitungs referat sehr umfassend die
frage nach der bedrohungslage in und um
europa analysiert wenn wir die
unterschiedlichen systeme ebene
betrachten das von der globalen system
eben über die geostrategische system
ebene das umfeld der europäischen union
der zustand der europäischen union
selbst
das system österreich als auch die
militär strategische ebene so lässt sich
bereits seit einigen jahren eine
verschlechterung der sicherheitslage für
europa aber auch österreich konstatieren
wir sehen und hier kann man den befund
zweiter feichtinger also nur voll
inhaltlich zu stimmen
eine immer stärker konfrontative
weltordnung eine forcierung unilateralen
handelns von globalen aber auch
regionalen akteuren und eine
infragestellung des internationalen
politischen systems und des völkerrechts
das jahr 20 20 war in diesem
zusammenhang beispielhaft auch das wurde
am heutigen tag am heutigen abend
mehrfach erwähnt risiken deren
eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten über jahre
hinweg als wahrscheinlich kategorisiert
wurden haben sich nunmehr materialisiert
cyberangriffe pandemie naturkatastrophen
regionale konflikte sowie
terroranschläge waren und wurden zur
realität
die noch immer reale herausforderung der
migration bei der feuchtinger hat das
auch erwähnt mit einem potenzial von
mehreren millionen menschen draht durch
die befassung mit anderen
herausforderungen zwar in den
hintergrund ist aber noch immer ein
thema dem wir uns hier auch aus
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitische
perspektive zu widmen haben der nach
langen diskussionen mittlerweile nun
doch vollzogene praxis als auch der
fortdauernde klimawandel bekamen
hingegen im jahr 2020 gleichsam zur
randnotiz
dieser trend der verschlechterung der
sicherheitslage für europa aber auch für
österreich hat sich auch am beginn des
jahres 20 21 fortgesetzt
sei es im nahen und mittleren osten in
afrika oder in asien
darüber hinaus ist europa und haben das
auch mehrfach das schlagwort blackout
gehört darüber hinaus ist europa und
damit auch österreich zu jahresbeginn
sehr knapp an einem blick hat
vorbeigeschrammt
all dies zeigt zum einen die
notwendigkeit einer faktenbasierte
strategischen vorausschau
und diese grenze hier auch entsprechend
begleitet zu analysieren und auch die
notwendigkeit sich mit dem risiko und
lagebild in einem permanenten prozess
auseinanderzusetzen dass
sicherheitspolitik und
verteidigungspolitik gerade in den
letzten jahren und jahrzehnten von einem
statischen system hin zu einer
dynamischen politikfelder geworden sind
dem auch policy makers es neudeutsch zu
formulieren entsprechend rechnung zu
tragen haben welche konsequenzen ergeben
sich nun aus dem skizzierten risikobild
aus der skizzierten bedrohungslage für
die österreichische und europäische
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik und
welche ausprägungen erfährt in diesem
kontext die landesverteidigung
ich habe es bereits erwähnt wenn man die
unterschiedlichen system ebenen
betrachtet und im rahmen des prozesses
unser heer wurde auch ein risiko bilder
auf die perspektive 20.30 also nicht nur
ein jährliches oder ein für ein paar
jahre gültiges risikobild sondern die
vorausschau für eine dekade erstellt so
lassen sich für österreich im
wesentlichen vier
verteidigungspolitische risiken
darstellen
erstens auch das oftmals gegenstand der
beiträge am heutigen abend hybride
bedrohungen
zweitens sich verschärfende konflikte im
südlichen und östlichen krisen bogen
drittens angriffe auf die europäische
union beziehungsweise einen
eu-mitgliedsstaat und viertens die
kategorie der souveränität gefährden
angriffe hinzu kommen und so auch wenn
sie nicht im fokus der
verteidigungspolitischen risiken per se
stehen
resilienz gefährden die extremereignisse
wie beispielsweise blackouts und die
auswirkungen der corvette 19 pandemie
auf wirtschaft und gesellschaft die
derzeit wunder kaum erfasst werden
können
geopolitische spannungen und
globalisierungs bedingte vernetzungen
und interdependenzen sowie eine breite
verfügbarkeit von technologie und die
industrie instrumentalisiert barkeit
radikalisiert ländergruppen erhöhen das
risiko hybrider bedrohungen
die von terrorismus und gewalttätigen
extremismus oft mit unterschiedlichen
hintergründen ausgehenden bedrohungen
für demokratie und rechtsstaat scheinen
sich zu verschärfen
darüber hinaus werden rasante disruptive
technologie entwicklungen der
organisationen und einzeltätern gänzlich
neue handlungsoptionen eröffnen
darüber hinaus besteht die gefahr dass
sich infolge von tendenzen
gesellschaftliche polarisierung
unterschiedliche erscheinungsformen des
gewalttätigen extremismus und
insbesondere auch des politischen islam
weiter ausbreiten
aufgrund der dargestellten
herausforderungen und entwicklungen und
der zentralen herausforderung durch den
begriff der hybriden bedrohungen sind
auch grundlegende
verteidigungspolitische planungs
parameter einem veränderungsprozess
unterworfen
angesichts der hohen unsicherheiten und
der komplexen wechselwirkungen zwischen
einzelnen risiken sind konkrete
eintrittswahrscheinlichkeiten für
einzelne szenarien nur schwer
prognostizierbar
oftmals und vielmehr stellt sich die
frage stellt sich die fragen nach den
einsatz wahrscheinlichkeiten für die
streitkräfte in diesem kontext die sich
ändernden risiko und bedrohung spieles
gemeinsam ist all diesen
herausforderungen dass sie nicht alleine
sondern nur im verbund mit partnern
wirkungsvoll in griff zu bekommen sind
bereits im jahr 2003 konstatierte die
damals erstmalig angenommene europäische
sicherheitsstrategie ein mittlerweile
schon fast vergessen in vergessenheit
geratenes dokument das kein europäischer
staat allein in der lage ist den
damaligen sicherheitspolitischen
herausforderungen entsprechend zu
begegnen sondern dass es der kooperation
und auch einer stärkeren gemeinsamen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik der
europäischen union bedarf das war das
jahr 2003 und ich erinnere nur an das
eingangs statement der europäischen
sicherheitsstrategie aus dem jahr 2003
europa war nie so frei so sicher sowohl
haben wenn wir diesen befund auf das
jahr 2021 umlegen so unterstreicht diese
noch viel deutlicher die notwendigkeit
nach kooperationen um diesen heraus
forderungen entsprechend zu begegnen bei
all diesen kooperationen gilt es aber
auch entsprechend darzulegen wie diesen
herausforderungen durch die
kooperationen am besten begegnet werden
kann beziehungsweise auch das gilt es zu
unterstreichen welche fähigkeiten
österreich reziprok kooperationspartner
auch anbieten kann
klar ist aber auch dass zu tiefe der
kooperation aufgrund unserer geltende
verfassungslage insbesondere der
neutralität auch klare grenzen gesetzt
sind
darüber hinaus muss man meiner meinung
nach auch mit dem irrglauben zu einem
gewissen grade aufgeräumt werden dass
kooperationen einsparungspotenziale wie
blick auf die nationale sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik bringen kooperation
kann nur funktionieren wenn es
fähigkeiten gibt mit denen man auch
kooperieren kann wenn hier nur wenig
vorhanden ist werden auch die
kooperationsmöglichkeiten beschränkt
sein
ich möchte im folgenden auf vier
themenkomplexe kurz eingehen und ihre
auswirkungen auf die österreichische
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
auch im kontext des prozesses unser heer
20.30 entsprechend eingehen beginnend
mit den hybriden bedrohungen hybride
bedrohungen und ich will niemanden
insbesondere auch nicht mehr nach
derartigen hybriden veranstaltung mit
definitionen und theoretischen
konstrukten lang weil aber hybrider
bedrohungen und ich glaube das ist sehr
wichtig zu unterstreichen zeichnet aus
dass das völkerrechtlich klar normierte
kriegs bild durch breit gefächerte oft
unvorhergesehene und unvorhersehbare
formen der gewaltanwendung ergänzt wurde
der graubereich zwischen einem offenen
bewaffneten konflikt und verdeckter sub
konventionelle angriffe wird der hybrid
agierende akteure ausgenutzt um die
völkerrechtlichen regeln zu umgehen
diese bedrohung kann nur durch einen
gesamtstaatlichen ansatz bewältigt
werden
das schwergewicht der
verteidigungspolitischen ausrichtung der
militärischen landesverteidigung ist
aber auf diesen hybrid agierenden
vorwiegend sub konventionellen gegner
auszurichten
ein wesensmerkmal dieser hybriden
bedrohungen liegt aber auch darin dass
strategische vorwarnzeiten zehn jahre
oder mehr
die früher für einen allfälligen wieder
aufwuchs militärischer fähigkeiten
genutzt werden konnten nicht mehr
existieren
somit steigt der bedarf an rascher und
flexibler reaktionsfähigkeit hohe
einsatzbereitschaft autarkie
beziehungsweise durchhalte und
durchsetzungsfähigkeit der streitkräfte
eine voraussetzung für die abwehr
hybrider bedrohungen ist zudem die
fähigkeit konventionelle und sub
konventionelle angriffe in allen domänen
insbesondere in der luft aber auch im
cyber raum entsprechend abzuwehren
dies liegt insbesondere darin begründet
dass ein hybrider angriff auch zu einem
konventionellen hochskaliert werden kann
verfügt das bundesheer verfügte
sicherheitspolitik über die hierfür
notwendigen fähigkeiten und kapazitäten
wirkt das abschreckend auf hybride
akteure bereits vor oder noch vor einen
potenziellen angriff es genügt aber
nicht hier den blick rein auf österreich
zu lenken sondern hier auch die
europäische dimension mit einzubeziehen
denn hybride bedrohungen inklusive des
informationskampagnen und
cyberbedrohungen stellen für
gesamteuropa eine direkte
sicherheitsbedrohungen da und damit auch
für österreich grundsätzlich und das ist
gegenstand auch der bearbeitungen im
rahmen des prozesses unser hier stellt
sich gerade mit blick auf diese
herausforderung die frage wie diese
hybriden bedrohungen am besten begegnet
werden kann
primär zu hause oder auch im rahmen von
umfeld stabilisierung
ich möchte daher in einem zweiten punkt
auf das internationale sicherheitsumfeld
ein wenig eingehen um hier quasi auch
die dimension der umfeld stabilisierung
als gegenmittel zur hybriden bedrohungen
ein wenig zu erläutern
weiter feuchtinger hat das plakativ
dargestellt dass die krisen und
konflikten an der europäischen
peripherie ein zentraler faktor der
europäischen sicherheits agenda bleiben
aktuell geben uns die spannungen um die
nutzer beispielsweise von erdgasfeldern
im östlichen mittelmeer
die lage im libanon und in syrien das
fortbestehen des atomar commons mit dem
iran
der amerikanische truppen aus abzug aus
dem irak und afghanistan sowie die
situation in libyen von der gesamten
region aber auch die situation in der
ost ukraine danach wie vor fragil west
balkan und der krieg und berg karabach
anlass zu besorgen ist in den
europäischen staaten und in der eu wie
nachhaltig die aktuell positive dynamik
im nahostkonflikt ist lässt sich heute
am tag des amtswechsels des
amerikanischen präsidenten noch nicht
wirklich absehen da die meisten in
österreich unmittelbar relevanten
risiken aus entwicklungen im umfeld der
europäischen union resultieren sind
beitragsleistungen zur reduktion soll
risiken oder abwendung von bedrohungen
im rahmen einer proaktiven umfeld
stabilisierung einschließlich
internationalen krisen management im
rahmen der europäischen union der
vereinten nationen der nato und der osze
auch mit robusten militärischen kräften
unabdingbar hier wird von österreich
weiterhin ein entsprechender beitrag
auch verlangt werden bereits jetzt wird
dieser seit mehr als sechs jahrzehnten
durchgeführte internationale engagement
des österreichischen bundesheers
international hoch anerkannt wir müssen
uns aber alle auch bewusst sein dass es
auch im bereich des internationalen
krisenmanagements einen richtungswechsel
weg von klassischen peacekeeping
operationen hinzu auch qualitativ
anspruchsvolleren missionen und
operationen gekommen ist gerade mit
blick auf diese operationen und
missionen sowohl im bereich der
gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik der eu als auch im
bereich der nato zeigt sich dass etwa
trainings und ausbildungs missionen auch
einen höheren anspruch an die qualität
der ins ausland entsandten streitkräfte
stellen mit der neuerlichen geplanten
übernahme der commander funktion der eu
trainingsmission mali im ersten halbjahr
2022 der beibehaltung des traditionell
starken engagement auf dem westbalkan
so wie im rahmen von ohne viel in
libanon bringt österreich deutlich zum
ausdruck dass es auch weiterhin seinen
beitrag zum internationalen krisen
management leistet und damit wesentlich
so umfeld stabilisierung beiträgt
es sei auch noch einmal hier die frau
bundesministerin zitiert das derzeit
sich rund 1000 soldaten im
auslandseinsatz befinden was mit blick
auf die größe unseres landes doch eine
beachtliche anzahl darstellt obwohl die
genannten herausforderungen und krisen
österreich direkt betreffen ist es und
ich habe es bereits erwähnt unmöglich
diese nur unilateral zu lösen sondern im
rahmen internationaler und europäischer
kooperation insbesondere die
entwicklungen der vergangenen jahre
zeigen deutlich dass kooperation immer
mehr zum grundprinzip der
österreichischen verteidigungspolitik
wird und dies auch sein muss das
beinhaltet insbesondere auch eine
möglichst aktive teilnahme an der
gemeinsamen außen und sicherheitspolitik
der europäischen union und der
gemeinsamen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik gsvp ich darf daher
in einem dritten super titel auf die
entwicklungen im bereich der gsvp ein
gegner und auch hier ableitungen für
österreich darstellen
wir erinnern uns alle zurück das er vor
etwas mehr als 20 jahren dieses projekt
einer europäischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik damals svb genannt
ins leben gerufen wurde
die ersten jahre waren von rasanten
entwicklungssprünge gekennzeichnet der
damalige hohen vertreter javier solana
sprach sogar dass sich die gemeinsame
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik mit
lichtgeschwindigkeit entwickeln würde
wir haben vielleicht ein wenig an vater
in den letzten jahren in diesem bereich
verloren
nichtsdestotrotz gilt es aber dennoch
auch vergangenen entwicklungen und
entwicklungen in jüngerer zeit im
bereich der gsvp hier hervorzuheben 20
13 wurde der europäische rat unter das
motto die fans meters gestellt zum
ersten mal seit dem inkrafttreten des
vertrages von lissabon befassten sich
die staats und regierungschefs der
europäischen union
explizit und schwerpunktmäßig mit fragen
der weiterentwicklung der gemeinsamen
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
daraus folgte ein prozess mit
qualitativen entwicklungsschritten von
der verabschiedung der eu globale
strategie über den start der ständigen
strukturierten zusammenarbeit der
einrichtung eines europäischen
verteidigungsfonds und erschaffen der
military planning und kontakt t mobility
die weitere graduelle schritte zur
weiterentwicklung der gsvp gesetzt haben
unter der vergangenen deutschen eu
ratspräsidentschaft wurden auch fragen
beitrittsstaaten beteiligung im rahmen
von best of der ständigen strukturierten
zusammenarbeit die einrichtung einer
europäischen friedens fazilität und die
ausarbeitung eines strategischen
kompasses auf den weg gebracht dieser
prozess des strategischen kongresses der
auf zwei jahre angelegt ist soll auf der
grundlage des gültigen ambition niveaus
gemäß der eu bei strategie zu einer
klareren zieldefinition was man im
rahmen der gsvp erreichen will beitragen
ausgehen sonst das ist ähnlich zum
österreichischen prozess von einer
gemeinsamen bedrohungslage soll eine
verbesserung des europäischen
krisenmanagements eine erhöhung der
widerstandsfähigkeit der eu und ihrer
mitgliedstaaten sowie auch die
verstärkte einbeziehung von partnern
erreicht werden österreich hat sich in
der vergangenheit sehr aktiv an diesen
prozessen im rahmen seiner
verfassungsmäßigen rahmenbedingungen
eingebracht neben der aktiven
mitarbeitern strategischen kompass
beteiligt sich österreich derzeit an
acht von 47 beeskow projekten bei einem
davon
das kann man auch mit gewissem stolz
sagen sie waren sowie jens as as service
als als lead nation als führungs nation
in diesem kontext auch eines der wenigen
projekte die bisher schon konkrete
ergebnisse liefern konnten für
österreich sicherheit ist und bleibt die
eu und so die gemeinsame sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik der entscheidende
handlungsrahmen gerade deswegen ist es
im österreichischen interesse auch
notwendig diese weitere
entwicklungsschritte sorgsam zu
überprüfen proaktiv mitzugestalten und
mit entsprechenden beiträgen auch zu
unterstützen sowie die auf europäischer
ebene getroffenen entscheidungen
internationalen streit
kräfte planung entsprechend zu
berücksichtigen der vierte punkt den ich
nur kurz noch ansprechen möchte sind die
auswirkungen von kogit 19 und anderer
residenz gefährden der extreme
ereignisse auf die sicherheits- und
verteidigungspolitik und in weiterer
folge auch auf die frage der aufgaben
unserer streitkräfte sowie 19 hat wohl
eindrucksvoll die verwundbarkeit unserer
gesellschaften aufgezeigt und wir haben
es mehrfach gehört ein anderes
schlagwort den ruf nach resilienz erhöht
ein unsichtbarer gegner der nicht
greifbar und nicht mit klassischen
mitteln zu bezwingen ist hat auch zum
teil zu neuen aufgaben für streitkräfte
in ganz europa geführt
die rolle der strategischen
handlungsrahmen und des militärs als
rückgrat staatlicher strukturen wurde
hier klar unterstrichen auch bei anderen
resilienz gefährdenden extremereignissen
wie beispielsweise einen
flächendeckenden blackout wie die
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik
eines landes auf den prüfstand gestellt
werden für österreich bedeutet dies dass
auch weiterhin beruf nach assistenz und
unterstützungsleistungen ergehen wird
und wohl zu recht von der bevölkerung
hier auch eine aktive rolle des
bundesheeres erwartet wird dabei steht
der einsatz des österreichischen
bundesheeres zum schutz der
lebensgrundlagen der kritischen
infrastruktur unter demokratischen
freiheiten im mittelpunkt das
österreichische bundesheer muss auch
weiterhin in seiner gesamtheit die
nationale handlungs reserve der republik
österreich für krisensituationen
darstellung in denen die souveränität
österreichs gefährdet scheint als solche
trägt es zur sicherstellung der
aufrechterhaltung des souveränen
entscheidenden politischen systems
österreich bei dazu muss es
und dies ist nur ein
alleinstellungsmerkmal von streitkräften
aber auch über entsprechende vorhalte
und durchhalte beziehungsweise
durchsetzungsfähigkeit verfügen
in meiner conclusio glaube ich gilt es
so und so wir sind hier gerade an diesem
punkt unser träger die aktien kann hat
das erwähnt dass wir intern gerade hier
beginnen die ableitungen in eine
entsprechende richtung
zu kanalisieren grundsätzlich gilt dass
mit blick auf das skizzierte risikobild
auf die verteidigungspolitischen
parameter mit denen wir uns
auseinanderzusetzen haben sich dennoch
die österreichische sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik im rahmen zwischen
verfassungs und einfach gesetzlich
determiniert und durch politische
grundsatz dokumente festgelegten
aufgaben der bestmöglichen bewältigung
der skizzierten risiken politischen
schwerpunktsetzungen sowie den
budgetären rahmenbedingungen bewegen
muss angesichts der hybriden bedrohungen
bedarf es eines erhöhten maß an
flexibilität der streitkräfte erhöhte
autarkie und durchhaltefähigkeit sowie
verstärkter europäischer kooperation
nur so kann der geänderten
verteidigungspolitischen planungs
parametern am besten rechnung getragen
und die landesverteidigung auch fit für
die sich aktuell und künftig stellenden
herausforderungen gemacht werden am ende
des tages ist es die resultate von
sicherheitspolitik nicht nur so wie wir
es heute tun über sicherheitspolitik zu
reden sondern sicherheit im interesse
der bürgerinnen und bürger zu
gewährleisten
dies bedarf eines diskurses der heute im
rahmen des tages der wehrpflicht ja auch
abgehalten wurde
es gilt hier aber diesen diskurs auch
konkret in die weiterentwicklung der
österreichischen sicherheits und
verteidigungspolitik umzusetzen
vielen herzlichen dank
herzlichen dank herr dr kamen an dieser
stelle würde bei einer herkömmlichen
live veranstaltung tosende applaus
einsetzen nämlich nicht nur für das
schluss referats sondern für alle
beiträge des heutigen tages der
wehrpflicht die in einer großen breite
eine profunde beschreibung der
gegenwärtigen situation gegeben haben
und uns einblicke in bedrohungsszenarien
in mögliche antworten von befreundeten
ländern gegeben und geboten haben aber
auch fragestellungen wie sie bei uns im
ressort gerade gewälzt werden
dargestellt wurden und es zeigt dem
interessierten publikum die
herausforderungen vor denen wir heute
stehen
in diesem sinne darf ich mich
stellvertretend für alle gäste die wir
live stream dabei waren erinnern ganz
herzlich für ihre beiträge
bedanken im sinne einer zusammenfassung
denke ich ist jahr geworden heute das
ist einerseits eine profunde
militärische expertise braucht um
sicherheitsbedrohungen zu analysieren
wir soldaten lernen uns immer auf den
worst case also auf das
schlimmstmögliche szenario vorzubereiten
und damit wollen aber sollen wir auch
sicherstellen dass die bevölkerung in
österreich schutz und hilfe erhält wenn
andere einsatzorganisationen nicht mehr
können
aus dieser perspektive wurden in den
letzten jahren zahlreiche aufrufe auch
von uns als plattform er hofft dass
österreich gestartet nämlich das
bundesheer zu modernisieren und
programme anzustoßen die jenen ähneln
wie wir sie heute von den kollegen aus
der schweiz oder schweden erzählt
bekommen haben
auf der anderen seite müssen wir aber
auch zur kenntnis nehmen als realität
zur kenntnis nehmen dass die politik
auch andere begehrlichkeiten und auch
andere bedürfnisse befriedigen muss und
daher geht es letzten endes
immer um geld und wer welchen anteil an
der wirtschaftsleistung erhält und doch
kann uns die krone ließ krise wären wir
rasch grundbedürfnisse des lebens im
vordergrund stehen können an die wir
vielleicht zuvor gar nicht gedacht haben
und so können wir vielleicht auch
ähnlich wie bei der gesundheit sagen
sicherheit ist nicht alles aber ohne
sicherheit ist alles nichts
daher sind wir überzeugt dass
sicherheitspolitik ein bereich ist bei
dem parteipolitik keine rolle spielen
darf
es braucht einen nationalen
schulterschluss über alle parteigrenzen
hinweg einen konsens darüber wie man mit
der frage sicherheit umgeht
um nämlich zu ermöglichen einen roten
faden dieser politik über einige jahre
konsequent zu verfolgen
daher wäre es ein anliegen einstimmige
parlamentsbeschlüsse über ziele und wege
der österreichischen
verteidigungspolitik zu erzielen
und ich persönlich denke dass dazu die
österreichische bundesverfassung der
passende kompass sein kann und auch sein
muss und diese bundesverfassung braucht
auch keine auslegungs experimente das
österreichische bundesheer ist um heute
den schweizer gast anzusprechen kein
schweizer taschenmesser das im dual use
verfahren manchmal als feuerwehr
manchmal als polizei manchmal als
gesundheitsbehörde eingesetzt wird
denn das österreichische bundesheer ist
nicht primär eine reserve für andere
einsatzorganisationen es ist einzigartig
keine organisation in österreich hat
unseren auftrag
wir sind die bewaffnete macht der
republik wir sind die strategische
handlungsrezepte der republik
wir sind schild und schwert der republik
das bedeutet aber auch dass es hinter
uns niemanden mehr gibt der einspringen
kann oder könnte wenn unsere fähigkeiten
und kapazitäten bereits ausgeschöpft
sind
mit diesen gedanken auch mit diesen
denkanstößen beende ich den heutigen
festakt zum achten tag der wehrpflicht
und danke ihnen für ihr interesse
es lebe das österreichische bundesheer
ist lebe die republik österreich